Let's go to some of the notable discussions
happening over on the David Pakman show subreddit.
Nearly 15,000 of our viewers and listeners
are now participating in moderated, respectful
political discussion@davidpakman.com slash
Reddit that's our E D D I T. very interesting
post pointing out or asserting that if Fox
news wasn't a thing, Trump would have been
impeached by. Now. I actually, I, I agree,
but this is a bit too simplistic and what
I mean by that is Fox by itself has actually,
particularly over the last six months, not
been the 100% reflexive Trump defending tools
that they were, uh, for the latter part of
the 2016 election and the early part of the
Trump presidency.
I would sort of frame it a different, different
way. The broader right wing media reinforced
by a social media algorithms. Echo chamber
is what is very different now than when Richard
Nixon was under impeachment in the 1970s.
So it's not Fox news by itself, although Fox
news, at least the opinion shows that still
love the guy like a Hannity and Laura Ingram
and you know, whoever else, they are still
a big part of it. But it's the broader ecosystem
that exists where you can have folks who are
only watching the Fox news shows that Trump
and they're watching, you know, one American
news and they're sharing fake news on Facebook.
And the algorithm is reinforcing that with
articles from Breitbart and uh, you know,
whoever else that is the broader it's, I would,
I would say it's more than Fox news, but you
are completely right in that, it is that ecosystem
that is one of the big differences between
impeachment, uh, around Richard Nixon in the
1970s and Trump now.
And we will see ultimately what it does for
Trump once we know the, uh, sort of full scope
and final results of the impeachment inquiry
that is going on right now. Also from the
David Pakman show, sub Reddit. Finally Pat
guest hosts the show, a user PDX pro courier
saying I would much rather see Pat hosting
the show than Farron cousins or Benjamin Dixon.
I like those guys. Nothing against them. But
Pat is the O G. yeah. And then they go onto
to say things that I won't say just because,
uh, our show is broadcast on FCC regulated
radio stations. Pat did a great job. I had
my emergency appendectomy a week ago and I
completely missed the Thursday show. Pat was
able to put together a compilation episode
with a nice introduction and he hosted the
bonus show. He hosted the bonus show on Friday
and actually did a couple of stories for you
on Friday.
Pat did a fantastic job and we are exploring,
we are exploring other spots where you may
be able to see more Pat for people who don't
like Pat. And of course there are people in
the audience who like and dislike anybody
who has ever been on the show, myself included
a don't worry, you are still going to be able
to avoid Pat if that is your priority. But
no, Pat did a great job and, um, uh, I really
appreciate all the comments. Not only wishing
me well, uh, recovering from my appendectomy,
but also, uh, the positive comments about
Pat join the discussion more than 15,000 other
viewers and listeners are participating@davidpakman.com
slash R E D D I T